Under the Influence is our topic tonight.
And I thought of a lot of different things.
And the one I kind of wanted to talk about was my secret influence.
There are people in our lives that are incredibly important to us.
And I would even mention to say some of the most important people, everybody aside
from my mother in my life, doesn't know anything about this person who I think
about every day, and his name was Michael Marquis.
And so if this were a violin piece, it would be called Ode to Michael Marquis.
I met him when I was seven years old.
And I was growing up, my mother had left my father when I was about two or three.
And this was the first man that my mother had brought home, like for me to meet.
And he was a Vietnam vet.
He was a professional athlete.
He had played college football, college baseball.
He was a ski instructor and a golf instructor.
He had like a big beard, and he drank scotch, and he had a German shepherd, and he had a lab,
and he had this unbelievable MG.
And not like those little like wussy MG's that you see, like it was like a 1933 MG.
It was like a motorcycle.
I mean, this thing was so cool.
And the doors like went super low, you know.
I mean, it was just so cool.
And he was so cool.
And he was the first person to really tap into, he may have tapped into it,
he may have created it, I'm not sure, but a mama's boy complex.
Which was that I had, I hadn't been, my father lived in Texas,
and I hadn't been to Texas since I was about three, but I was obsessed.
I had a Dallas Cowboys belt buckle.
I would wear like, you know, flower t-shirts, you know,
like Grand Parsons or something like that.
I mean, this is about 1977.
I was very into that.
I only listened to Willie Nelson's The Red-Headed Stranger.
My room was covered with cowboys and broncos and Indians,
and like anything Texas was up my alley.
And he met me, and he's like, why, what's all the Texas stuff, you know?
He's like, well, you know, my dad lives in Texas.
Well, he ain't here, is he?
I'm like, no.
He's like, well, I think I'd get over the Texas thing if I were you.
I'd be like, you know, that really hurt my feelings.
And he proceeded to like latch into this thing, like, so what, are you mama's boy?
Cowboys lost today.
Did your dad call?
No, right?
I mean, he's a very tough guy, very tough guy.
And through a little bit of what my mother felt was kind of abusive behavior,
I grew to love him, right?
I mean, I hated him, but I loved him.
I thought about him all the time and what he would think about something.
And like, for example, he decided that since I was so into football,
but you don't know how to play football, you know?
What, did your dad teach you to play football?
No, I don't think he did, did he?
All right, come on, let's play football.
No, I'm not looking for the pity thing.
It was really pretty funny.
I mean, he was a funny guy.
He was trying to help me in his own weird way.
So he takes me outside, he takes me outside, and he says, all right,
I'm going to teach you how to play football, all right?
But football is a man's game, it's not a mama's boy's game, all right?
You make a diamond with your hands, your thumb to your four fingers,
and if you can touch it, you can catch it, all right?
So I'm like, all right.
Bam! You know, and I was, and he's like, you still with me?
You still want to play football?
Huh? I'm like, yeah, I want to play football.
He's like, all right, if you can touch it, you can catch it, all right?
Bam! You know, and it just went on.
I mean, and it was freezing outside, and my nose is bleeding, and I'm crying,
and I want to go inside, and he's like, you know, you've got to catch this football, right?
And so finally, I catch it, like, three times.
He's like, all right, see, you're not such a little mama's boy, after all,
and I feel kind of good about myself.
I mean, you know, I don't want to have me go figure, you know?
So my mom really liked him, and we moved to Vermont, and he took us,
and he moved us into this one bedroom, one, not, it was just a one room cabin in Vermont,
whereas he had this gig as a ski instructor, and it was really picturesque,
and he really had it in his heart, like, to teach me how to be a man, you know?
And we would, he taught me how to chop wood, and he bought me a jeans jacket,
and he would have my mom do, like, patches on the back, you know, and it was really very cool,
and I started to feel very cool.
He took me to see The Man Who Would Be King, and, you know, I cried at the end,
which is, this is a digression, I'm going to regret doing this, but it's my favorite line,
since I have an audience, I have to tell you, it's like, Sean Connery is standing
on the burning bridge, and Michael Caine shouts, he's, the bridge is burning, he's going to die,
and Michael Caine scouts out, you know, peachy, will you ever forgive me for being so bleeding,
so stupid, and so bloody arrogant, and Sean Connery says, you know, that I can, and that I do, you know?
And, like, Michael and I sat there, and I just cried, and he was just like,
pull yourself together, man, you know?
We got in the car, a guy's a little M.G., and it's, like, freezing, and I'm crying, and he's like, come on!
It was a good movie, it was sad, but it was, you know, you gotta, you know, I loved it, too, I loved it, too.
But from then on, in my mind, like, Michael and I were, you know,
Michael Caine and Sean Connery on adventures and things, and we had them, you know?
I mean, I had to walk, I mean, it's really kind of picturesque, I had to walk, like, two miles to school,
and I was only in second grade, and it was very fun, he insisted that I do it, you know, by myself,
and my mother had a lot of problems with him, like, the, the, like, when my mother would go,
she had to go to town a couple times, and he would take me on dates with other women,
and, like, if you tell your mother, I'm gonna kick your ass, and I thought it was great.
I mean, again, like, you keep being judgmental, and I was like, I was like, this guy is so cool.
And I remember I, like, rolled joints for him for this other girl.
I don't know, I have this vague memory of it, but, and finally, like, my most pivotal memory of him,
aside from the closing of my story, is, is we had, you know, this little one-room cabin,
I mean, it was really, really idyllic, snow, and Vermont, and all this other stuff,
and, and Michael, we're out on this little deck outside of it, and Michael's like,
see that, look at that buck, look at that buck, look at that, get the shotgun, Ethan, get the shotgun,
you know, and I'm like, I'm like, what for? He's like, we're gonna kill it, you know,
and I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, Mom, Michael's gonna kill a buck, Michael's gonna kill a buck!
And Michael goes, you, I was gonna let you shoot it.
You blew it, you know, and I didn't know how I felt, because I didn't want to shoot it,
but now I felt like I should have wanted to shoot it, and like, I don't know, I felt very strange.
Doesn't exactly make sense, but you can understand the subconscious, very influenced.
And so, finally one day, I come walking home from school, this little cabin,
and all my mother's underwear and lingerie, kind of like things,
are nailed to the outside of the house, right? This is a true story, all right?
And I'm like, wow, that's weird, you know? And, and, and, and inside there's like,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And, you know, we basically get in a car and we're gone.
And we move to Atlanta, Georgia.
And, you know, I don't know any more about what happened there than you do.
I mean, long charade, I can guess, you know, but I've never asked my mom,
my mom has a lot of issues, but that's not, this is Michael's ode.
And so anyway, we move to Atlanta, Georgia, and what happens is,
my father gets remarried, and for some reason, to my now eight-year-old mind,
this is very disturbing.
I'm not invited to the wedding, and I'm very upset about this,
and it's kind of throwing my whole Texas fantasy scheme apart.
And I get, but I'm in this like weird school in Atlanta, Georgia,
and I actually get accepted to this little gifted and talented program,
like for an eight-year-old, right?
And I go to, and I get kicked out on the second day
because I told some kid that his painting sucked, right?
Or the teacher, I didn't get kicked out right away.
I had to write a one-page essay about why I would, you know,
I was supposed to write about why saying somebody's painting sucked was a bad thing.
And I wrote in my essay that I didn't know that it was something bad
because my mother goes out with lots of guys,
and the last one that she dated told me I sucked all the time,
and I didn't think it was that big a deal.
Now, that sounds like, the truth is, I knew exactly what I was doing.
Like, it wasn't like I was trying to make my mom look bad in front of the teachers
to like deflect, you know, me being in trouble.
My mom was so angry at me.
She got this call from the teacher, and she hangs up,
you little shit, you know?
Well, I don't date lots of guys, and Michael didn't say you sucked.
Yes, he did. All right, he did.
But, you know, like, blah, blah, blah.
And anyway, the point is, and then I got in a fight,
and I got kicked out of this gifted and talented thing,
and it was like a big deal, and my father's getting remarried,
and they send me to a child psychologist,
and my mom comes up with this idea that she's going to invite Michael to come to my birthday,
like that I could really use this, right?
But I don't know about this, but so my birthday arrives,
and we're living in Atlanta, Georgia now,
and who comes down the street in a little MG with the golden retriever
right in the side of the thing, and his hair and his beard,
and he's got this, you know, thing and a bunch of presents in the back,
comes pulling up, and it was really one of the greatest moments in my life.
I mean, I was so happy to see him,
and I had all these boys come over for my birthday party,
and Michael took turns taking us around the block,
and he would like peel out fishtail around the thing,
and my mother would be screaming,
Michael, get him in, and all the boys would be like,
your dad is so cool.
And I'd be like, I know, I know, he's so cool.
And it was really one of those glorious days.
Michael took us all to Chuck E. Cheese's,
and we went to see George Burns in Oh God,
and everybody was just so into Michael,
and I, by association, was a very studly guy.
And so then it's the night's over, and Michael's going to leave.
You know, Michael says goodbye, and I say, all right, see you later,
and he starts to go, and I go to my room, and I start sobbing, right?
And so my mother comes in, and it's like, what are you crying about?
It's like nothing, nothing, you know, I just,
I wish Michael was going to stay longer, you know,
and she's like, all right,
and she goes outside, and okay, but yeah, go, go, go.
And it's very good, very good timing, very good timing.
Like Pat Riley would say, it's all good.
So much for him.
But so Michael comes into my room, and I'm devastated,
because as much as I would like,
and everything for him to talk to me and everything,
I am so upset, you know,
and I really don't want him to see me like this, you know?
And he tells me that, you know, he's going to stay in touch with me,
and that don't worry, you know, my mom's a pain in the ass,
we all know that, but I'm going to stay in touch with you,
you're a great kid, you know, and he might have even told me he loved me.
I mean, he was really being really nice.
And he drove from Vermont to Georgia for a day.
And so, and then he leaves, and you know, like I watch him drive away,
it's like night now, and I watch the MG and the golden retriever like take off,
and my mom comes back in the house and I hear it,
and I just scream out the room like, I am never going to speak to you again.
You know, I felt so betrayed by her, because if Michael was going to leave,
I wanted him to think I didn't care, you know?
And he, and I never saw him again, you know?
And I got a message, my mother got a message about two or three years ago,
something that she Googled Michael Marquis.
No, she didn't, that she had heard from him,
and that like he saw some movie I did and thought that I was doing really great.
It really meant a lot to me because, you know, nobody I know knows him,
but I carry him with me every day.
And he's been the secret influence of my life.
Thank you.